in teatro vige il detto che il pubblico
ricordi come inizi e come concludi e che
tutto quello che combini al centro come
dire in qualche modo lo dimentica Ma pur
essendoti atlanti io questa teoria non
c'ho mai creduto molto quindi oggi
facciamo che Opto per farmi ispirare
dalla natura da questa meravigliosa
natura nella quale siamo immersi in
questo momento così sono sicura di non
combinare pasticci ok
come ho raggiunto la consapevolezza
della mia forza e contestualmente della
mia vulnerabilità
attraverso la mia voce o meglio
attraversando la mia voce proprio come
si fa quando si Varca un portale e
parlando di voce questa cornice a Mena
mi porta alla mente la teoria di Darwin
che sosteneva il canto sia stato
inventato dagli uccelli e che lo stesso
linguaggio umano abbia preso origine Dal
canto degli uccelli e
avviene in quanto gli individui di una
stessa specie emettono dei suoni per
esprimere le loro emozioni di fatto
pensiamoci quando siamo felici o
Innamorati noi cantiamo no girando il
sugo stirando oppure no il classico
sotto la doccia dai alzi la mano Chi
canta sotto la doccia
e gli altri tutti afoni Vabbè ve la
passo oppure al contrario quando
proviamo dolore o rabbia Ho paura
urliamo
la voce vola proprio come un uccello e
volando attraversa i colori le
temperature gli odori e quanto raggiunge
te si trasforma in ciò che tu desideri
in ciò che il tuo inconscio custodisce
la tua mente elabora e trasforma
Ma la vera magia è che nessun canto
possiede in sé un significato
particolare in quanto è libero è tuo ed
è tutto ciò che desideri
la vita è un palcoscenico noi dobbiamo
essere protagonisti e non spettatori Beh
quante volte abbiamo sentito queste
frasi sono tra le più ricorrenti ma
soffermiamoci un attimo qui Proviamo ad
immaginare la nostra vita come un'opera
teatrale con noi stessi protagonisti
ruolo principale non personaggi
qualunque che subiscono passivamente le
azioni degli altri
all'interno della società ognuno di noi
ha un ruolo è un personaggio e c'è chi
recita improvvisando chi invece seguendo
un copione E questo rende appunto il
teatro non avere proprio la metafora
della vita e il mondo un gigantesco
palcoscenico nel teatro come nella vita
reale Esistono gli lieto fine come il
finale tragico e questi sono i due poli
esattamente opposti che però nella
quotidianità di un individuo vanno a
mescolarsi dando il via ad un
susseguirsi di avvenimenti che forgiano
la personalità questa persona e
appunto
dettano poi la natura del finale della
nostra vita ma questo dipende
esclusivamente da come noi decidiamo di
recitare nella nostra opera teatrale ma
visto che oggi via mi piace
metaforizzare Apriamo un altro scenario
Come trovare la direzione per
raggiungere la bellezza pensiamo dei
cartelli stradali Sì quando guidiamo
veniamo invitati a rimanere all'interno
di certi predefiniti limiti di velocità
e di sicurezza mentre noi sempre più
forte incalzante sentiamo il desiderio
di schiacciare il pedalino destro e
superare quel limite è una sorta di
spinta interiore bene
quella spinta esattamente ciò che dentro
dobbiamo alimentare E certo sia chiaro
magari non quando guidiamo ma ogni
qualvolta il sistema vuole farci sentire
limitati inadeguati al di sotto di
qualcuno qualcosa
è un veleno a lento rilascio che
schiaccia nell'angolo i nostri sogni che
offusca la visuale sulla nostra unicità
unicità è già aver fatto la differenza
in quanto noi siamo il cocktail del
nostro vissuto e non esiste un vissuto
uguale ad un altro Quindi siamo un
prodotto assolutamente unico
a tale riguardo Esplorare i nostri
limiti Ma attenzione limiti intesi come
l'imitazioni che spesso ci detta solo la
nostra mente bene Esplorare i nostri
limiti ci conduce all'interno di
territori vastissimi Ed ecco che i
limiti non diventano altro che
opportunità per evolversi per
trasformarsi e perché no A volte anche
per ritrovarsi
La realtà è che noi stessi siamo i più
grandi limite che possiamo incontrare in
quanto nulla è più efficace di ciò che
noi diciamo noi stessi e non affidiamoci
soltanto i nostri sensi perché loro si
innevitabilmente sono limitati perché si
affidano a parametri che gli impone la
ragione o questa materia che gioco Forza
Sì è limitata di fatto noi non odiamo Se
non entro una determinata distanza o non
vediamo se non entro un certo raggio
visivo mentre la percezione È senza
limiti
ho un notizione sì ho un notizione la
macchina del tempo esiste il teatro il
teatro è un magico portale che ci
trasporta ogni volta in una realtà
diversa
luce buio tenebre gioia amore tormenti
sacrificio Estasi
quando ho scoperto che il teatro è un
evasione da questa realtà non sono mai
più stata in grado di guarirne
Avete presente sicuramente quelle
emozioni tanto forti e totalizzanti da
non poterle spiegare a parole ci proverò
ho debuttato per la prima volta in
teatro nel Rigoletto di Giuseppe Verdi e
ricordo precisamente il transfert che
avvenne io ero lì ma non ero più
Isabella improvvisamente ero Maddalena
catapultata Sulle rive del fiume Mincio
nel mantovano in una bettola malfamata
con mio fratello Spara Fucile
fratello Ma Isabel non ha fratelli
eppure lui era lì con me in carne ed
ossa avevamo una storia insieme capite
una vita parallela alla tua che ogni
volta che sali sul palcoscenico
incredibilmente si materializza ed è
sempre tua eh diciamo
in prestito per qualche ora ma è di tua
proprietà è l'evoluzione di te
infinite versioni di te e pensiamoci
improvvisamente attorno a te parlano in
lingua antica
drappi di velluto legni scuri e ti muovi
in una dimensione mai esplorata dove
Oggi sono la regina di Francia domani
una Ninfa del Bosco oppure una sigaraia
ribelle
è una grande magia sì
e io il mio portale l'ho trovato
sicuramente molti di voi
ricorderanno il film Matrix
vero mio leletto collegava questi questi
suoi cavetti dietro la nuca ed entrata
in questo mondo virtuale mondo sì
virtuale ma dentro la quale poteva
provare emozioni poteva provare dolore
paura soddisfazione nascere addirittura
morire
Ebbene Io ho sempre pensato che il
teatro
è Matrix Mentre qui è la navicella
Nabucodonosor
Ebbene sì
io il mio portale credo si sia capito
L'ho trovato auguro a tutti di trovare
il proprio portale perché un portale
vuol dire poter fuggire rimanendo
assolutamente Fermi aprendo un libro Una
carezza un cucciolo il sorriso di una
nonna qualunque cosa
una ferrata tutto
tutti noi abbiamo bisogno ed esigenza di
avere quel varco da oltrepassare che ci
porta via da qui che ci porta nella
nostra comfort zone e ci e ci salva è un
po' una nostra zona di protezione
occorre
lottare ogni giorno e occorre ripetere
solo dai ripetiamolo Lotterò
lo terrò
e lo terrò perché è vero Sì la vita ci
pone gli ostacoli Ma i limiti li poniamo
soltanto noi quindi niente limiti ma
solo Orizzonti
[Applauso]